hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one of the key ideas that readers of
Martin heidegger's famous lecture what
is metaphysics often find most difficult
to grasp and drafter their heads around
so to speak is this this action or
property or however we want to conceive
of it actually none of these are
adequate that has to do with the nothing
that Heidegger in translation is calling
me halation in his German he actually
talks about das Nick's nicht it
so the nothing literally nothing he's
turning nothing from a noun of sorts
into a verb an action word and so the
question is well what what is this and
it turns out to be a little bit less
mystical or obscure or or complicated
when we look at the text closely then a
lot of people make it out to be and it
has to do with the relationship between
design and being as as a whole or a
totality that is grasped through the
mood of anxiety we saw that the mood of
anxiety reveals to us the nothing so
Heidegger is going to tell us that in
anxiety something happens with being
they reveal themselves to to us in a
certain way and that it's not
annihilation and it's not negation as
such these are going to turn out to be
dependent upon the nothing and what he's
calling the negative behavior of the
nothing or another way that he talks
about it is a wholly repelling gesture
so we need to get at that and this is in
this section the response to the
question he tells us that in anxiety
there's this shrinking before and it's a
kind of bewildered calm it affects both
the the design of the human being the
core what it is that the human being is
in their existence and the totality of
beings that they are in
within remember that design is one being
among other beings although it's a very
special kind of being and what we saw is
that beings as a whole in anxiety are
revealed to us or reveal themselves to
us as in retreat as moving away from us
Heidegger uses these spatial metaphors
and then he talks about the nothing
itself he says the nothing does not
attract it is essentially repelling but
this is a different kind of repulsion
than we might think of in terms of like
repugnant or negative you know response
to electromagnetic stimuli or something
like that instead he's using metaphors
here too you know we don't we have to
use spatial metaphors it is it is
repelling he says this repulsion is
itself as such a parting gesture so you
know think of waving goodbye or it might
also be a parting gesture like screw you
you know or any any other sort of thing
but it is it is pushing beings away and
these beings are as he said submerging
as a whole there they're losing their
their meaning you might say and he calls
us a holy repelling gesture towards
beings that are in retreat as a whole
and he says this is the action of the
nothing that oppresses design-in anxiety
so one of the things that the action of
the nothing is is a pressing design a
pressing you know the person in how they
feel
so the nothing is is intrinsically
involved in the very feeling mood tuned
meant however we want to translate it of
anxiety that turns out to be one of the
most important moods for Heidegger for
revealing reality to us so that's one
side of it the other side is the beings
he goes on and he says this is the
essence of the nothing me halation this
is this is what the nothing does you
could say that the nuff
is not merely a negativity a privation a
lack it and it's not something either
this is why it gets quite difficult to
wrap our heads around but it also does
something notice we can't avoid this
something language can we and that is
nihill ation so he goes on and he says
this is not an annihilation of beings it
doesn't completely destroy them or
reduce them to nothing because then the
nothing wouldn't be doing anything in
relation to something right so it's not
a violation and he says nor does it
spring from a negation the nothing as
we've seen is prior to negation and
kneel ation the action of the nothing is
thereby also prior to the logical
intellectual operation of negation so he
goes on and he says that nothing itself
nihill eight so this is this is the
phrase that drew a lot of criticism from
people who you know not just ordinary
people what are you talking about but
also from other philosophers who said
look you're treating the nothing itself
as if it's something or you are doing an
illegal operation with language there's
sort of a lot of legislation of what
language and logic can do and Heidegger
could actually say yes you're right from
the perspective of the logic that you're
using this does not make sense this is a
sort of nonsensical jargony type of type
of phrase that I'm coining but if we're
talking about the reality itself it
actually does have meaning and it's a
meaning that we can grasp experientially
existentially through anxiety so he goes
on and he says kneel ation is not some
fortuitous accident it's not something
that just happens or that we could strip
away and get rid of at some point rather
he says as the repelling gesture towards
the retreating whole of beings here's
where we get to something really
important what is it what is this kneel
ation doing we saw already that it
oppresses design does it do anything
else he says yes it discloses though
beings in there full but heretofore
concealed strangeness as what is
radically other with respect to the
nothing so you might say that to use
another very important phrase and hide
your coins the nothing is what allows
beings to be to be fully what they are
it provides them with a kind you might
say a kind of contrast it allows their
features to come out in the fullness of
what they are not for the nothing but
for design for us for our experience of
them because nothing is engaging in its
action of annihilation towards these
beings that are retreating as a whole
that we grasp through anxiety we're able
to understand we're able to sense we're
able to find ourselves thrown into the
totality of beings as a whole with the
actual strangeness that they do present
to us a sort of radical otherness to
nothing but also to ourselves so he goes
on and he says it's in the clear night
of a the nothing of anxiety
the original openness of beings is such
arises that they are beings and not
nothing see before that we were taking
the beings for granted and we you know
he had all that sort of wordplay at the
beginning of others beings and nothing
else but nothing has some sort of
whatever it is it's not being because
it's not a being but it's there with the
beings and it's what allows the beings
to be what they are so he goes on and he
says this and that nothing we add in our
talk is not some kind of appended
clarification it makes possible in
advance the revelation of beings in
general so the activity of the intellect
in thinking about the totality of beings
turns out secretly to be dependent upon
the nothing
you might say something like a condition
for the possibility of what we call in
philosophy of transcendental condition
it's also what is going on in anxiety
which also grasps beings as a totality
but those so in an effective way rather
than in a strictly cognitive way so he
goes on and he says the essence of the
originally nil ating nothing live in
this this is the essence of the nothing
according to Heidegger that it brings
designed for the first time before
beings as such this does not mean of
course that before there is this
experience of nothing and of its action
of nee elation that that you know design
is not related to beings of course it is
related to beings it's in the midst of
beings but in order for us to grasp
beings as beings not just as this book
that blackboard or even you know certain
universals that we might make of them
words that we might use to apply to them
in order to grasp them metaphysically
Heidegger would say we have to take into
account the nothing and fortunately for
us when we are in original anxiety we do
indeed take account of it even though we
may not fully understand it in a
cognitive way we grasp beings as such by
the wholly repelling gesture the knee
halation of the nothing
you